je veux savoir pourquoi les aurores
boréales en punk couleurs les couleurs
dans les aurores boréales dépendent des
gaz dans l'atmosphère de notre planète
on a ce vent solaire qui arrivent et qui
vient frapper les gaz de l'atmosphère de
notre planète est dépendant de la sorte
de gaz
est ce que c'est de l'oxygène est ce que
ces deux là zot on va voir des couleurs
différentes
la couleur qui dominent généralement
c'est un espèce de blanc verdâtre mais à
l'occasion on va voir du rouge de
l'indigo du jaune
on va voir aussi du pourpre alors
dépendant de la nature des gaz dans
l'atmosphère de notre planète les
couleurs vont changer
merci